배신 어 배신 배신이 있었죠 나쁜
놈들한테네 그런 친구들은 다
[음악]
사라져요 안녕하세요 비캐스트 김지
있니다 대표님들 혹은 자녀분들 요즘
공부 다들 어디서 하시나요 독서실이나
스터디 카페 많이들 이용하실 텐데요
그 중에서도 대한민국 독서실 스토디
카페 시장 1등 점유율을 자랑하는
작심 다들
아시죠네 오늘은 작심을 운영하는 기업
ing 스토리의 강남구 대표님과
함께합니다 안녕하세요 대표님네
안녕하세요네 대표님 간단히 소개한
말씀 부탁드리겠습니다 저는 프리미엄
스터디 카페 브랜드 작심을 운영하고
있는 ing 스토리 대표 강남구라섹
네 아버지께서 어머니께서 부자되라고
이름을 강남구로 지어주셨습니다 아네
너무 특별한 이름을 가지고 계셔서
궁금했습니다 제가 대표님께서 이은
나이에 사업을 시작하신 걸로 아는데
사업을 처음 시작하시게 된 계기가
있을까요 저는 고등학교 졸업하고 이제
창업을 바로 했는데요 고등학교 때
제가 잘하고 못하고 뭐를 좋아하는지
정확하게 알지 못한 상태에서 남들이
다 대학교를 간다고 가는게 큰 의미가
있 있을까 해서 부모님이랑 고민 상담
끝에 사회에 바로 나와서네 제가
잘하는게 뭔지 싫어하는게 뭔지를 좀
깨닫고 나중에라도 공부를가 필요하다면
하겠다라고 말씀드리고 일을 계속
하면서 뭘 좋아하는지 배우고 있습니다
나는 사업가가 돼야겠다 이런 확신을
갖게 된 계기가 있다거나 아니면
그런게 있을까요 확신을 가졌던 계기는
단 한 번도 없고 부모님 사업이
중간에 어려워지면서 꼭 돈을 많이
벌고 싶다 성공하고 싶다는 막연한
꿈을 가지고선 돈을 많이 벌려면
어떻게 해야 될까 하니까 회사 밑에
들어가서 일하는 것보다는 내 회사를
하는게 돈을 가장 많이 벌 수 있겠다
생각이 들어서 시작을 하게 됐고 하다
보니까 업계에서 이제 1등을 하게
되고 또 이게 지속적으로 유지가
되면서 또 책임감 같은게 생기고 그
책임감 안에서 또 명예로운 스토리를
또 남기고 싶다 보니까 조금 더 의미
있는 회사로 발전시키려고 좀 다양한
시도들을 하고 있는 거 같습니다
대표님께서 팀원에서 잠깐 근무하셨던
걸로 알고 있 인데요 당시 영업
1등을 놓치시지 않으셨다고 들었어요네
정확하게 알고 계시 혹시 그 영업
1등을 놓치시지 않으셨던 비결이
있다면 어떤게 있을까요 제가 어린
나이에 이제 2살에 회사를 들어가다
보니까 저보다 절대적으로 연륜이 높은
사람들이 많았어요 그러다 보니까
상대적인 그 경험치를 따라갈 수
없어서 절대적인 시간 투자 자체를
일반 영업하는 분들보다 두 배 세
배를 노력을 했던 거 같아요 저를 사
때 회사에서 만났던 분들은 제가 술을
먹는 거를 상상을 못 해요 왜 저는
맥주 한잔도 안 마셨고 아 한 일곱시
쯤 집에서 나와서 한 시간 정도
걸려서 안양에서 강남까지 출근을 했고
그 사무실에 도착해서 회의하고 저는
현장으로 나가서 사무실에 밤 11시
12시쯤 들어와서 새벽 2시 30분
정도까지 댓글을 직접 달고 다시
안양으로 퇴근하고 잠 조금 자고 다시
나와서 다시 강남으로 출근하고 이게
저의 인생이 사이클이 있거든요 2살에
22살을
계속네네 그렇게 해서 저는 누구보다도
열심히의 대한 기준을 상당히 높여
놨던게 1등을 유지할 수 있고 1등을
할 수 있었던 배경이었던 거 같고
저는 회사를 창업을 조그만하게
했었다가 팀모이라 회사에 인턴으로
입사를 한거다 보니까 두 번째 이유가
뭘까 생각해 보면 어떻게 보면 전는
다시 돌아갈 수가 없기 때문에
누구보다도 자존심 더 세고 나는 꼭
성공해야 되겠 대한 의지가 좀 높았던
거 같고 그러려면 지금 누구보다도
열심히 해서 빨리 승진해서 대표가
다시 창업하면서 돼야 됐기 때문에
누구보다도 열심히 또 했던 거 예
그런 것들이 좀 복합적으로 생게
아닌가 생각이듭니다 너무 대단하신데요
대표님 대단한게 들리죠 근데 그냥 또
그냥 열심히 한 거예요 그 열심히
하는게 쉽지가 않잖아요 근데 이제
입대를 앞두시고 진로 교육 사업을
런칭을 할 준비하시다가 한번 조금
일이 있 있으셨아요 그렇게 어 그
배신 어 배신 배신이 있었죠 나쁜
놈들한테 아네 그런 친구들은 다
사라져야 너무 세상이 무너지는
기분이었을 것 같은데 그럼에도 다시
일어설 수 있었던 원동력이 있었을까요
안 된다고 생각해 본 적 없다 이게
저한테 되게 중요한 문장인데 어쨌든
내가 포기할 수는 없고 나는 가야
되는데 이거 가지고서 내가 멈출 수는
없으니 하다 보면 좋은 기회가 오지
않을까 해가지고 계속 열심히 했던 거
같아요 배신한 친구들을 뒤로하고 또
다시 함께할 수 있는 친구를 군대
가기 전에 계속 찾았고 그렇게 또
찾아 지더라고요 또 새로운 비즈니스를
군대 안에서 작심이 서비스를 저녁하기
전에 런칭을 했는데 또 배신을
당했어요네 근데 또 배신 또 당했는데
어찌됐든 내가 또 다시 물리치고 다시
내가 이겨야 또 되니까 또 열심히
살고 하다 보니까 또 경쟁관계에서
어쨌든 그 경쟁하던 친구가 없어졌고
저만 이제 또 성장하게 됐고 그리고
그 수많은 그 과정에서도 너무나 많은
일들이
있었지만음 지금은 결국에 대한민국
1등 브랜드가 된 거죠 정말 많은
일이 있었네요 대표님 군생활 하시는
중에 이제 작심 서비스를 준비를 하신
거잖아요 많고 많은 사업 아이템이
있는데 독서실을 택하신 이유가
있을까요 제가 멋있 척 하려는게
아니라 진짜로 진로교육 회사를 처음
창업하다 보니까이 사업을 접으려고
생각해 보니까 아예 전혀 다른
비즈니스를 하면 다시 0에서 시작해야
되는게 너무 싫었어요 그래가지고
조금이라도 이거를 살려서 할 수
있는게 없을까 고민하다 보니까 한
사람 인생이 사이클을 보면 진로를
설정한 다음 진학을 하고 진학을 한
다음에 취업을 하고 취업을 한 다음에
나이가 들면 다 은퇴를 하면서 창업을
하더라고요 치킨 칩을 차리던 프리랜서
강사 활동을 하든 그래서 결국에는 한
사람 인생의 사이클이 진로 진학 취업
창업인 나는 진로 교육한 대상이
학생들이 한 100만 명 정도가 되다
보니까 우 교육을 받은 친구들을
대상으로 그 다음 스텝을 가는 걸
공간으로 풀어보면 어떨까 해서 저는
스터디 카페 독서실 모델을 알게 됐고
그때 당시에 뭐 카페를 할까 모인
공간을 할까 스토리 카페를 할까 되게
고민이 많았었는데 그중에서 이제
시장이 막 성장하고 있었던 스타디
카페 시장에 뛰어들게 됐고 그게 지금
이렇게 기회와 운이 잘 맞아 떨어져
가지고 노력이라 지금 이렇게 매장이
많이 늘어나게 된 거 같습니다
1호점을 런칭 하셨을 당시에 강남을
중심으로
내 강남을 중심으로 이게 프리미엄
독서실이 좀 많이들 생겨나고 이렇게
좀 파도를 타고 있었던 시기였던 거
같은데 1호점을 청주에 내셨나요 맞아
그렇게 저에 대해서 조사를 많이
하셨네네 맞습니다 감사합니다 어떤
사업 전략이 있으셔서 그렇게 시작을
하신 건지 궁금한데요 어 사실은 그
뭐 전략은 없었고 호점을 운 좋게
작심이 거를 직영점을 내고 가맹점을
내야 되는데 지경점 낼 돈이 없어
가지고 제가 A4 지 한 열장 정도
되는 곳에 3D 같은 걸 그려 가지고
사람들 건물주들을 소개 받으러
다녔어요 그래서 그중에 한 건물주께서
어 그럼 자기 건물에 한번 해
봐라라고 해서 그 건물에 시설 투자
비용을 다 지원해 주셔 가지고 매장을
내 주셨어요 1호점을 감행 정으로 아
그게 청주에 있는 용암동의
건물이었고네 그 건물이 3층짜리
건물이었는데 그 3층을 다 익스테리어
공사를 클래식하게 1900 돌로 하고
매장을 저희가 오픈하다 보니까
사람들이 좀 주목하는 지방 이집 한
번쯤 가보는 그런 매장이 돼 가지고
저희들이 기회를 얻어서 매장을
폭발적으로 낼 수 있게 됐어요 혹시
그 건물주 분과 나중에라도 이야기를
나누시다가 그때 어떻게 저를 믿고
진행을 하시게 되셨는지 여쭤보신 적이
있나요 뭐 나중에 물어보지 않았고 그
처음 선택했을 때 물어봤는데 세상에는
저도 돌 아이지만 지경점 없이 가맹점
낸게 진짜 미 어 그 특이한
거잖아요네 그 특이한 상황을 믿고
감행을 낸 사람도 더 특이하잖아요
세상에는 저보다 더 특이한 사람이
많다 근데 그분들이 항상 하는 말씀이
저를 보면네 건물주 분들이 본인의
어릴 때의 모습을 보는 거 같다며
되게 또 저를 또 이렇게 칭찬해
주시더라고요 제 칭찬인지 건물주님
칭찬인지 모르겠지만 그래서 어쨌든
열정이 있게끔 살았던 저의 모습을
높이 평가해 주셔 가지고 선택해
주신게 않을까 저 생각이 듭니다
단순히 생각해보면 하시는 사업이 단순
시설 투자업 이다라고 보실 수도
있잖아요 그렇다 보면은 좀 진입
장벽이 낮다라고 느끼실 수도 있는데이
진입 장벽을 높이기 위해서 하셨던 또
다른 전략이 있을까요 대표님 여러
전략들이 있는데 말씀하신 대로 이걸
시설장 취업으로 보고선 뛰어들었던
많은 기업들이 지금 많이 없어졌어요
예를 들면 현대 카드에서도 독서실
사업을 했었고 is 동서에서 독서실
브랜드에 투자해서 사업을 했었고
유니슨 캐피탈이라는 사업 펀드에서도
크게 투자를 해서 수백억을 투자해서
독서실 사업에 진출을 했었고 그
외에도 많은 유명한 프랜차이즈
본사에서도 했지만 결국에 저희 회사가
잘 살아남았고 경쟁에서 이기고 나머지
브랜드들이 다 없어지거나 또 축소한
이유를 제가 잘 보면은네 단순히 시설
투자 업으로 이걸 보고 뛰어들었기
때문이 정말 맞다 어 왜냐면 버텨서
볼 때는 그냥 인테리어만 하면 될 거
같은데 저는 좀 다르게 생각했던게
결국에는 남들이 하는 그런 인테리어로
갔었을 경우에는 진입자 장벽이 없고
시간이 지나면 지날수록 진입
장벽이라는게 쌓여야 비즈니스도 더 큰
기회를 얻을 수가 있는데 어떻게
진입장벽을 쌓을까 고민하다 보니까
대한민국의 자기주도 학습하는 사람들이
가장 많이 많이 모인 공간이 어디까
생각하니까 그 독서실이 그럼 그
자기주도 학습하는 사람들이 가장 많이
모인 공간에서 가장 많이 소비되는게
뭘까를 또 고민해 보니까 온라인 교육
컨텐츠였다 시방 모델과 만화방 모델을
보면 우리는 공간에 대한 비용을
지불하 하지만 내가 하고 싶은
게임들이 다 공짜이고 내가 공간에
대한 비용을
지분면적 아요요 그런 것처럼 독서실에
있는 타겟 고객이 가장 많이
소비하는게 온라인 교육 콘텐츠라는
생각을 하게 되니 그럼 나는이
독서실에 온라인 교육 콘텐츠를 PC
방과 만화방 모델로 만들면 이건
대한민국에서 좀 의미 있고 공간에
마케팅 할 수 있는 창고에 대한
재정의가 아닐까 하는 생각이 들어서
저는 교육 컨텐츠 프로바이더 역할을
할 수 있는게 독서 스터디 카페다
그래서 누구보다도 빠르게 우리나라의
1등 그런 교육 콘텐츠 회사들
접촉해서 단기간에 독점 계약을
체결하고 남들에게 알려줬었는데 남들이
계약을 못 하도록 맞고 저는 그
자본을 투자를 받아서 그 기간을
벌어서 했던게 크게이 시장을 바꿔놨던
거였고요 그리고 두 번째는이 콘텐츠
프로바이더는 역할을 하기 위해서는
시스템이 받쳐 줘야 되는데 야놀자와
여기였네 그리고 배달의 민족과 요기를
보면은 과거에는 전화해서 프로모션을
물어보고 쿠폰북을 보고 주문을 하거나
전화를 하거나 예약을 했던 시스템들이
결국에 앱 하나에서 모든게 결제되는
것처럼이 독서실 스터디 카페도
컨텐츠라는 것들이 전화로 어떤 컨텐츠
보고 싶습니다 듣고 싶습니다 이렇게
하는 거가 안 되고 시스템으로 되기
위해서는 독서실 스터디 카페 예약
시스템 안에서이 컨텐츠를 클릭하고
넘어가서 코드가 발급되는이 시스템이
만들어 줘야지만 가능하겠더라고요
그래서 보니까 어 독서실 스터디
카페가 과거에 야놀자가 나오기 전
그리고 배다리 민족에 나오기 전 이런
쿠폰북 시장 모텔 펜션 호텔 예약
시스템 시장인 거 같더라고요 그래서
저는 독서실 스터디 카페 회원 관리
프로그램이 노후화되고 낙후된 걸 보고
우리들이 수직 계열화 시킨 다음에
독서 스터디 카페를 한대 묻고 예약이
되게끔 만든 다음에 굳이 프로모션을
전화로 안 물어보고 앱에서 해결하게
만들고 컨텐츠를 여기서 프로바이더
역할를 하게 되면 마케팅 채널이 될
것이고 더 나아가서는 항공권을 미리
구매하면 쌓듯이 우리가 어떤 시간대
좌석에 잘 팔리고 어떤 시간대 안
팔리는 거를 알게 될 것이고 그럼 안
팔리는 시간대 그 지점들에 우리들이
프로모션에서 자석을 더 잘 팔리게
만든다면 우리들은 직영점을 보유하지
않고도 다른 사람들 매장으로도
우리들이 직영점 수익을 실현할 수
있는 어떻게 보면은이 시스템 안에서
새로운 수익 창출을 낼 수 있고 이게
아가 접목이 돼서 새로운 정의가
내려질 수 있겠다라고 보고이 두 가지
기회를 보고 진입장벽에 만들려고
투자를 많이 했었죠 그런 어
인사이트나
모델들은 어 어디서 주로 영감을
받으시고 고안해 되시는지 너무
궁금한데요 갑자기 저는 동종업계
분들도 많이 만나지만 전혀 다른
분야의 분들을 만나서 그분들이 우리
우리 분야를 볼 때의 시각이 어떤지를
되게 많이 궁금해 해요 아 그리고
아까 말씀드린 대로 야자나 여기어때
배달의민족 이런 서비스들 지금 하고
있는 다양한 서비스들이 저는 업종만
변경했었는데 작심 독서 스터디 카페
접목할 수 있는 전략이다 전 많이
생각이 들더라고요 그래서 전혀 다른
업종의 사람들을 많이 만나려고 노력을
합니다네 이런 얘기 드리게 좀
그렇지만 지금 부동산 경기는 저희에게
너무 좋습니다 대한민국 1등 브랜드
바보 브랜드 중 마제스트라는 것도
최근에 인수했고 어떤 건물 좀
만났더니 나 임대 안 나가도 돼 근데
나 멋있는 거 들어왔으면
[음악]
죽겠어 m